a global brand how VW plans to become
number one in the interview Volkswagen
Group CEO Martin Winterkorn you're the
CEO of Volkswagen and a trained
automotive engineer what do you find so
fascinating about cars if like me you
grew up in the post-war 1950s or 1960s
you grew up with cars as your main form
of transport
you learned about vehicles and mobility
from a very young age and if you happen
to have grown up in South West Germany
close to the town of sufen house where
you get to see lovely Porsche cars every
day difference of hozen then you
automatically develop an interest in
cars that's why I'm glad I became an
auto engineer this being pinnacle killer
did you know now a Porsche belongs to
Volkswagen making it even more enjoyable
I'm very happy about that because when I
was a young boy I'd see Porsches being
test driven in my hometown and that's
why I'm delighted that the Porsche brand
is part of Volkswagens emil four
thoughts falcon plans to become the
number one car maker in the world why is
that so important obvious mother I'm
going to say something now that
journalists don't like to hear our
objective to make Volkswagen number one
to make it the biggest automakers
emerges from other objectives we've said
we want to have the most satisfied
customers we want to have the most
satisfied employees we want to achieve
good results so we can invest in the
future and we want to build the best
cars as a result will be the biggest and
best car maker in the world by 2018 are
you sure you will get there by 2018 I'm
quite sure there's going to be plenty of
serious competition of course there are
two big car makers with similar
ambitions Toyo
and GM it's definitely going to be an
interesting three-way race to 2018 what
products does Volkswagen have to offer
to get there I believe Volkswagen must
and will have the most attractive
products that will satisfy our customers
around the world we're not just talking
about Germany not just talking about
Europe but about the world just to make
that clear we sold over three million
cars in China last year we're talking
about the u.s. we're talking about
Brazil the Asian markets and Russia in
all of those regions we need to make our
products attractive that's why I say we
have to develop construct and produce
cars that above all satisfy our
customers they'll only by another folks
wagon if they're satisfied and when they
buy another folks bargain our customer
base will be so big we'll be number one
but that will mean producing different
cars for the Chinese market the Mexican
market and the US market that's
absolutely right and that's why we're
traveling a lot to different markets to
try out our cars in specific countries
in Russia China the US Japan Brazil and
Mexico and of course Europe and if you
look at the demands our cars have to
satisfy in China which is an important
market due to its sheer size then we
have to build a lot more glamour into
our vehicles we on the following also
bigger bigger with softer seats why
softer seats a Chinese person weighs on
average 20 kilos less than a European we
have to make the upholstery softer in
Europe we have a more sporty approach
we're also discovering that size is of
great importance in China like it was in
Europe in the 60s and 70s we're building
bigger cars in China because the Chinese
want bigger cars we have to satisfy
demands important is the Chinese market
- Volkswagen the Chinese market is very
important to us right now as I already
mentioned we sold over three million
cars there last year
and China's going to continue to
you're sure of that I'm quite sure
though I've also been reading some
gloomy er things about China lately I
doubt those assumptions will happen we
have a very good network in China we
have 17 factories there we're doing a
lot to help rebalance the spread of
wealth in East and West China wealthy
Chinese live mainly in the East poor
Chinese mainly in the West we build a
factory in northwest China and we have
many factories along China's eastern so
we have a very good network in China
making cars for the Chinese market but
we're also exporting cars from Europe to
China engines and gearboxes to we're
securing jobs in Europe thanks to our
presence in China just to mention one
figure we've exported over 200,000 cars
from Europe to China
Volkswagen still looked upon as a German
brand in China we looked at as a
European car maker that's a very
important aspect for the Chinese I don't
think there's a nation outside Europe
where branding plays such a big role as
in China a Chinese person will never buy
a Montblanc pen if it's a fake they'll
always want to buy an original and when
a Chinese person buys a Volkswagen
they'll want a folks like it's the same
with Audie it doesn't matter if it's
produced in China or Europe they need
the brands you're also an advisor to the
Chinese premier what are you telling him
it's use it's them from if you look at
Prime Minister Lee's priorities they're
quite similar to Europe first the
environment second fighting corruption
third the issue of balancing wealth in
the East and West fourth solving
infrastructure problems in the big
cities and dealing with China's traffic
problems and if you look at what Prime
Minister Lee has already achieved you'll
see how bogus tea is and how clear he is
and his goals speaking as someone who
has gone through all this in Europe in
the 19
fifteen 60s and 70s I think he's got a
good adviser to support a guru Baba
you're optimistic about the Chinese
market but how do you view other markets
the US for example we're also optimistic
about the US the US will continue to
grow perhaps not as fast as last year
but thanks to the new Gulf which is
about to go on the market and which
we're presenting in Detroit next week
we're quite confident that the
Volkswagen brand will continue to grow
through daeun Porsche will grow anyway
to mention one figure last year we sold
over 600,000 cars in the US the
Volkswagen brand has broken the 400,000
barrier for the second time and I'm sure
we'll grow even more in the US the
business has not been easy for Fox
bogging it's been tough for some of the
brands and VW stable though not others
last year the Volkswagen brand sold over
400,000 cars
I admit we'd have liked to have sold
even more but competition is part of
business as it is everywhere in the
world competition has been very strong
again in the u.s. what we have to do now
is be even better what innovations can
we expect to see from VW as I mentioned
we're going to see a new Gulf in the
u.s. we're going to give facelifts to
and upgrade quality in the Poisson Jetta
and beetle ranges we have plenty of
ideas that will continue to make our
cars attractive in the US what kind of
performance will the car of the future
have the second fall so exciting the car
of the future will definitely be one
with as low emissions as possible the
car of the future will still be using
conventional fuels but it will also be
electrically powered when it comes to
digital technology it will set new
standards we have to make our cars more
networked what does that mean more
networked what will it look like imagine
it like this your car will be talking to
my car
could be an interesting discussion the
discussion might be there's a traffic
jam up ahead drive around it or your car
tells mine if you're looking for a nice
restaurant go to the ritz-carlton or my
car could tell your car get out of the
way that might also happen what I want
to say is that this type of network that
we already have with the internet will
be extended to the car we'll need to
redesign our interiors they'll need to
be quite different from today so the
next wave of innovation will definitely
be in this area you lead a company with
well over half a million employees how
do you manage a company like that one as
big as that it must be a big challenge I
think the most important thing about
leading such a company is that you have
to give the employees of vision our
employees knows that our vision is that
we have a very clear goal for 2018
another important point for me is that
when we make a new car like the golf
sportsvan for examples which went into
production a few days ago is that I can
visit the factory speak to the employees
and ask them what they think of the car
they're all car experts we're dealing
with a very competent people in the
factories 30 or 40 years ago we had semi
skilled employees but today they are
highly skilled they have excellent
training many are engineers giving them
the feeling that we're building
beautiful cars that were there for them
that makes it relatively easy to lead a
company like this independent of that we
have 12 brands and 12 boards of
directors and management and so in that
way we've structured everything with a
stable hierarchy a personal question to
round things up you're a devout
Christian does that affect you in your
daily work as a manager even I've
described how we stand with regard to
our employees as a Christian I feel very
responsible for the future of our
employees we're not just talking about
five hundred seventy thousand employees
if we include our suppliers car dealers
and family members we're talking about
over 10 million people who are dependent
upon decisions made by the concerns
management I believe that it fits with
our image with my image as a Christian
that I feel responsible for my daily
actions for these employees you can look
at it like this Christianity is about
nothing more than paying attention to
our employees and making sure that
they're fine that they feel fine and
aren't worried about the future so in
that respect I think it fits in with me
being a Christian and it's still fun
thankfully yes otherwise I wouldn't have
been able to do it for so long I'm a
passionate car man and it's a pleasure
everyday there's nothing better than
developing new cars and if you see these
cars it's a pleasure to look at them and
believe me it's a lot of fun to drive
them every day thank you